how's the lawn doing
i actually do it in school
good good grazer
good
man we should
eventually get back to where she could
see me and
we got to eat and stuff like that
but i i don't know if that day ever
again
that's what i'm gonna talk to you about
what um
so
[Music]
if the only thing
that you've been interested in is the
best interest for alana
then
we have to sign
some papers i've got
this paper right here
[Music]
this is like for us to gain sole custody
of a lawn yeah from june
this isn't me coming at you with a
dagger
or anything like that you feel me
i just want to be able to take care of
lawn like i have been taking care of
alona and there are certain legalities
keeping me from taking care of elon
it's an ass that you do this with me
so i can take care of alana like i'm
supposed to
it's in her best interest
that is medical bills and for college
and she's getting ready to go
she'll be 18 and a heartbeat you know
i'm saying
yeah it's gonna be hard for me son
finding all the rights over and just
basically signing her out of my life
as a father i could never ever ever
imagine having to sign my rights away to
my child especially to another person
but in this case
he knows that she's safe where she's at
he also knows that lana would much
rather live with us and now she's
where she belongs with us
all right now
she's the only thing i got
[Music]
you